[Music]
works changing software and robotics are
ushering in a new age of automation in
this age there will be losers the
machinery is actually start to get
remote control which is which making
things a lot worse and hired us to find
job and there will be winners I hope
there will be more automation because
that brings a digital value to
businesses and growth in economy the
rewards and losses will not be evenly
distributed though both socially and
geographically I know for a fact in a
couple of years most factory work will
be overtook by robots which means it
will be less people work which means a
lot of people's go back to work
but it's unstoppable and it's driven by
all of us as businesses fight for the
tiniest edge over their competitors
customers one reliable service they want
efficiency they want the convenience and
that's what we're able to deliver here
we carried out new exclusive research
throughout the UK the results match the
ghost towns of tomorrow the more
automation we have below made the rich
for personnel when I first started here
this room would be full and there DVD
people over there and there's one County
the robots are coming for
Northamptonshire
some automation will be slow creeping
through the whole economy but other
automation will be sudden and drastic in
specific sectors what's called cliff
edge automation
Sky News worked with researchers like
Alice to pay the most detailed picture
to date of automation in the UK UK wide
nearly 18 percent of jobs are at risk of
cliff edge automation but here in
Northamptonshire that number rises to
more than 22 percent of the top 10 local
authorities most at risk in the UK 3 are
in Northamptonshire alone and 7 are in
the Midlands more generally and in Corby
as much as a third of jobs are under
threat the worst rate in the whole of
the UK it's really hard because
obviously I don't like saying I own I'd
prefer being out there working he's
working just keeps my mind off a lot of
things
Rhys is a 19 year old who's worked in
factories and warehouses around Corby
for the last two years getting short
term gigs through employment agencies
what sort of work in mundane rapping in
strapping which is most majority of the
warehouses I was doing is wrapping and
strapping picking and packing and that's
it the old factories it was different
I was the working of a factory there was
literally no no machines no nothing it
was just literally hands-on so it was
just loads of us doing picking and
packing and strapping and wrapping which
it was good that way because it was good
without no machines there because we all
done at my hands and I moved back here
and it's just to do with machines after
machines I tried to apply for a
warehouse and that requires daily job
was going through the robots which I had
no idea because I ain't trying to heard
that know nothing about which means I
can work there because I was not trained
do you feel like robot said taking jobs
here in Corby yeah obviously my dad is
not here because he's obviously at work
but he works 12 hours and he works on
the robots I know for a fact in a couple
years most factory work will be overtook
by robots
which means it's going to be less people
working which means a lot of people's
gonna be out of work because of it how
worried are you for the for Corby is a
town it is bad it really is because
there is hardly any jobs going when
heavy industry left Northamptonshire in
the Midlands in the 80s and 90s a new
type of worker was needed lying in the
middle of the country on major motorways
and became a distribution hub instead
with factories and warehouses those
replacement jobs they turn out to be
just as replaceable some industries are
more at risk than others in
transportation more than half the
workforce will experience automation for
manufacturing it's just less than half
of jobs and in retail and wholesale 44%
of jobs are at risk one of the companies
here
Festo is itself pushing automation in
their center automated milking machines
are assembled and dispatched to
customers alongside automatic DNA
sequences scaled-down versions of
automated factories like this one are
used to retrain clients employees for
the future of work festos Managing
Director is a qualified engineer with 25
years experience in technology and 2
degrees really
according to her we should learn to stop
worrying and love the robots ultimately
they'll bring more jobs I do believe
there is scare mongering going on out
there I think it can be quite confusing
for business leaders to decide what's
right what to believe which claims are
valid what do you think this sort of
economy looks like in 10 years country I
think innovation the pace of innovation
is going to be faster than a lot of
people expect but the pace of adoption
will vary and I think that what would a
factory look like in the future
certainly there will be more automation
I hope there will be more all more
automation because that brings
additional value to businesses and
growth in the economy in terms of how
people's jobs will change
looking at the systems that is behind us
there are ways of can complement work
and ensure that people become more multi
skilled without having to go through a
lot of intense education because
assistance and intelligence is there to
help them to do a wider variety of work
20 miles south of Northampton and Milton
Keynes a new distribution center is a
glimpse of the future of work Christine
started here as an agency work at like
Reese but she since been made a
full-time employee less than years I've
been in there husband ever was like this
so clean so I suppose
we are working together it's our
partners not only machine is only human
so it's really great place the water
morning guys
Christine's boss Caroline started at
John Lewis in Milton Keynes 14 years ago
originally working in a store she
swapped the shop floor for the factory
floor and has been here for six and a
half years now few drops come in like
two minutes just be aware of it makes it
a lot more efficient in what we do did
give anything back to sort of if this
was like a traditional warehouse or
warehouses in the past where you have a
picker walking up in denial spectrum
product what this does if this actually
just brings the product direct the
picker making us a lot more efficient in
what we do but don't think you're ever
gonna get completely get move away from
that human touch I don't think we want
you either
I mean for me the sort of the human
touch really complements the automation
and it doesn't replace it customers one
reliable service day one efficiency they
want the convenience and that's what
we're able to deliver here and
potentially in the future it could
reduce the amount of additional roles
that are created but what we are doing
is ensuring that actually those roles
that we do create I've got much more
opportunities
back in Northampton on a Saturday night
pay day on Friday means people are out
and about
automation of war come in waves physical
low schooled labor is most at risk as
robots replace manual work but the next
wave is software has automated systems
takeover cognitive functions to this
taxi company in Northampton has
implemented automation in all parts with
business
customers can order cabs using an app
voice recognition on the phone or as a
machine in the kiosk
the result is fewer humans and a lonely
night shift in a taxi control center
with evening bells crispy cap and a Help
Center site where would you want it flow
Chris helps run this taxi business the
oldest in Northampton it was founded in
1958 as a family firm but it's now owned
by an automated software company Chris
started as the driver before moving
off-road into the office working in five
years so five years so you see if ever I
change
I've seen a lot of change here what's
been the biggest change Automation has
been the biggest change yeah and when
computers and things first came in and
the automated systems came in I wasn't
very keen on it but within probably a
month of systems being bought into where
I was working I loved it
hundreds of things going in previously
that would have been people on the
telephone with a pen and paper writing
it down it would have been says look
whiter it said this is very much quieter
yes it is
you haven't got people shouting across a
room even just two three years ago there
would have been ten people is that yeah
I don't know anymore what is only four
or five of us say today so that's 50
furnace it's the future this is just
everything is automated do you worry
that you'll be automated I think there's
always gonna be a need for somebody to
be sitting here because there's the
human element of the driver so yeah you
needed a human this end just to sort it
out or we get drivers cars there well
I'm not being troubled every
so if you can hold on to your job or get
retrained by your employer you can ride
the wave of automation
but some people already being left
behind by the next Industrial Revolution
if you don't have a job like Reese's
friends Sean there's not much to do in
Corby except hang around the shopping
center he's angry and he doesn't want to
be identified in case his opinions cost
him a job the machinery is actually
start to get control remote control
which is which making things a lot worse
and hard of us to find job just gonna
cost them a lot more money tries to get
the robots fixed when they can just get
people think humans work quite well yeah
because we ain't got any wires in us
with blood and bone and muscle so we
just a lot easier to work even though
they bring the robots in so it's quicker
cost point to make a cent quicker when
the robots could have problems the one
thing young people kept telling us they
needed was training both from schools
and employers in those factories work
with robots they should train as young
people up while we can while we're young
and then when the time does come and
most factories will obviously be overrun
by robots then those teenagers will not
have no excuse to not be any jobs so
we're being jobs obviously change
working with the robots but those
factories don't do it they just put you
on whatever they put you on the point is
we're not powerless in the face of
automation we're not the inevitable
victims of robots and their owners
knowing where automation is going to
happen than happen soon as our data
shows means we can take action
retraining current workers and young
people work may be changing but we need
to shape that change the one thing you
never give up on what you dream off
obviously working jobs are hard to find
but people shouldn't give up that easy
we've got the ability and the rights to
work I ain't giving up
[Music]